see far is like a delicious intellectual  cocktail there's lots of ingredients  it's very satisfying it's very enjoyable  it is fantastic in its impacts it will  drive better health outcomes betters  Seattle outcomes better outcomes for the  planet that we live in whether it's how  we school our children whether it's how  we Stewart our planet whether it's how  we think about disease and health  outcomes advanced research is absolutely  necessary to deal in the complex and  integrated world that we live in it's  very easy to get excited about see far  because you get little windows on so  many important things that the greatest  minds in our country working with the  greatest minds around the world are  thinking about researching and trying to  drive change so it's a cool place it's a  great opportunity to see what's  happening by the smartest people in the  world and it has lots more to give going  forward